hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar titled
from protein structures to drug
discovery
novel therapeutic opportunities i am
michelle
ashton of labyrinth and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker amal
hassan ali
post-doctoral researcher at the
institute of medical physics and
biophysics
sherate in berlin germany for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
among you may now begin your
presentation welcome
oh thank you so much really um thank you
all thanks chelsea michelle
and everyone from gibko and samuel
fisher
for giving me this opportunity to talk
about
my field of research structural biology
and how we use
a study of proteins and structural
biology to
design therapeutic molecules and to
target these proteins for
uh looking for therapeutic approaches
and so
i'm amal i'm from um the
university of um charleston here in
berlin
i'm a poster currently as a protein
crystallography
lab and working with gpcrs together with
my
supervisor my mentor uh dr patrick
sheila
at the institute of medical physics and
biophysics and i'm so excited actually
to take you through
my research and a bit from my phd my
former phd
projects as well but before that i want
to give you
just an overview about myself yeah
that's some pictures from my peach
defense last year in march this was very
exciting moment
but before that i actually um did my
bachelor and my master
in a completely different way in a way
um i'm coming from a biotechnology
background and i was working with stem
cells and
more in cell biology for studying with
development biology for regenerative
medicine so i was already
kind of orientated in the field of using
research for
more clinical application but i thought
after my master that i want to change
with the field and so i had six months
of student fellowship in the structural
biology lab
where i get really in love with proteins
and since then
i'm still working with and so i spent
three year and a half almost in
um in the lab of a professor my
professor martina bologna is my phd
father
and where i really learned a lot from
him and from the lab and of course from
my projects and so i had two main
projects
where i started to fit into this
structure of this drug design
with really two interesting and very
actually challenging
proteins an ion channel called acid
sensing iron channel and i will take you
through these details later on my slides
and the second project was more protein
protein complex with
nanobody and that was really interesting
as well
projects during my phd i traveled with
vets because i applied for a fellowship
called instruct that give me
gave me the opportunity to
go to different facilities in order to
realize
and succeed with my project so i was
also in the weissman institute and then
uh to oxford together with isabel morris
in uk
um where we uh start the expression and
the characterization of
the ion channel and now currently i'm a
postdoc
again with patrick um and i
kind of change fields in a way like
changing target but i'm still orientated
in the structural based drug design and
now i'm working with
gpcrs mainly with those called
adhesion gpcrs and very exciting for
this project
that i'm doing now i have started in
february this year
and yeah let's see how things will go
but along with the science i'm also
trying to do science communication i'm
not
really science communicator but i'm
trying to take uh audience outside the
let's say the science puzzle uh to see
what we are really doing in the life so
you can find me in
instagram where i'm sharing more also
from my personal life
and also in twitter where it's more like
formal
and more scientific uh uh
slides like uh science uh platform
and also i'm sharing uh there more
about behind the scenes of uh of my
research
uh this is also some pictures from my
plans because i'm really fascinated
about planting stuff in my home and you
can
if you enter my home you can find
already garden
waiting for you so i love that
um so coming back to the science i'm
really um now trying to orientate my
career into the structure of this drug
design and how
we can use the study of architecture of
proteins in order to rationally develop
therapeutic approaches and so through
these years i gain
a lot of experience of course and
expertise mainly in
crystallography so using x-ray for
determining the structure of these
proteins and also
again a lot of experience and soul
culture
i use different expression systems and
that allowed me really to have
kind of the um eye to choose what is the
best for
uh for my target that i'm studying and
of course uh um
as for drug discovery i use a lot of
um studies into membrane proteins and
protein protein complexes
as well as also uh in vivo systems and
that's
very important when you wanna um yeah
check your
um your small molecule of your ligands
that you want to
love as a truck all right so in this
presentation that i'm really excited to
share with you
and today i'm going to take you through
what is the structure of this design
first of all and how
we can use it for the dissolve and the
design of molecules as its drugs
and then i will take you through the
challengings and the opportunities in
this field
uh by showing you the examples from my
research and then i will focus more into
my bloodstock
project but before that let's uh first
of all understand what
proteins are as i've mentioned here
protein are the main really building
blocks of our life so if you look to
your hair your
hair color if you're not dyeing your
hair or to your nail shape your
even your eyes and how we perceive um
colors outside and how we uh we hear we
smell stuff it's all mediated by
proteins that
really control these uh these
mechanisms in our body they play a
really a critical role in our body
function and how we move how we
we do stuff in our life in normal life
and so proteins
are large very large uh and
also known as complex macromolecules
uh if we look in a close look into these
proteins you can
see that they are made up by hundreds of
thousands these small units these pearls
here
called amino acids and we call it in our
field primary structure because it's
this
chain uh that from this in a certain
orientation and a certain confirmation
then give up to
[Music]
as a consequence give up this secondary
structure
made by alpha helix here and peter
sheets now
the combination of these two together or
even
of one of those together will give rise
to
the what we call the the third structure
dimension the three-dimensional
structure of proteins
where they are combined in a really
specific
way and precise way and i can't stress
more in this really correct
folding of alpha helix and beta sheets
because
it's very important for the correct
functionality of the proteins
now if we have a mixed
amino acid already from the primary
structure to
miss what we call a single point
mutation
it can then change the whole structure
as a consequence and then that's how we
get also what we call
the pathological proteins
um what are the techniques used for
having
information about the three-dimensional
structure there are a
wide range of techniques and it depends
actually
uh what is your question and the size of
your protein
and different parameters but these are
the most important
so um i mainly use x-ray crystallography
and and now start to learn how to use
also single particle triangle
perhaps hopefully in the future as well
tomography that will allow me even to
study proteins in cells
really without uh bypassing let's say
the
um the stress that we we do for our
proteins
when we extract them from their native
environment
and so if you the main let's say limits
of extracurricular crystallography is
that you
don't study the proteins in their and
their
flexible and dynamic way but
we rather study a state of these
proteins and normally proteins are very
flexible
and of course dynamic and if you want to
do that you can use
nmr or sax or other techniques that
allow you to study proteins into
solution
however there is of course a limitation
in terms of size because the size that
you can use for
nmr is pretty small whereas with
crystallography or with crayons
we uh we explore large complexes
and yeah those the techniques that i'm
using
now already you know what proteins are
what techniques are used you can follow
me into
uh the structural based drug design
definition and
uh yeah as the name say it's the design
of these
molecules or ligands that will be
developed as the tracks is based onto
the structure
and there are actually two field in this
uh in this
actually uh two subfield in this field
if i it's correct
it makes sense uh what is called
ligand-based
track design and structural-based drug
design because there are two ways of
starting this
drug design one is mediated when you
by having a library of ligands so
in this case your biological target is
kind of
unknown and so you start screening a
library of biological targets that
um somehow would be targeted by your
license
and what i'm studying is the structure
base design so i'm
defining i'm already having a biological
target and then i start to
look for small molecules or other
partners that
originally target my protein and i'm
showing this picture because to
to give you further insight in what we
mean with
uh rational design so you have to find
uh a ligand or uh whether it is a small
molecules or another protein that
fit perfectly so as you can see here
with your target and it's specific
potent but
also able to be active in
physiological conditions now the
pipeline in both of them is pretty much
similar
so we we combine in silicon analysis as
well as
experimental uh data that validate as a
consequence
this interaction between your ligand and
uh your your protein and in this way
after
all this screening we find one hit or
two
probably um that have the best effect on
our
protein and so
um i here i'm really suggesting to you
some
uh some revenues which i found very
interesting actually and i
always kind of trying to be updated all
the time with
what is uh the state of the art of
structural based drug design
where you can go further into this field
and have
more insight all right so
again i'm gonna show you the challenging
and what are the opportunities on this
field by showing you examples from my
research
and so here two examples actually three
one is the protein protein uh complex um
which is my
by showing you some examples from my phd
project
with a nanoparty and in the second part
will be more focused into
membrane proteins which are more even
challenging everyone
in the structural biology field knows
how
it's hard really to get uh structure and
characterize them
even experimentally membrane proteins
and you will know later on why all right
so starting with the first example which
is protein protein complex i'm gonna
show you this uh
example with uh that was already my
paper published so you can have also
uh further details into that uh the gel
saline mutant so it's
actually what we call the amigos disease
and
it's a rare disease rare genetic disease
uh
gelsin is composed it's a protein it's
plasma protein composed of six domain
and as you can see here you can find it
in the cell in two
active forms if you want to into
conformational
conformation and so uh in the
inactive uh form or when the protein is
not function you can find these six
domains are very close to each other in
a compact way
and once they interact with a specific
concentration of calcium then
the protein assume an open confirmation
state
and become active and when it's active
it's able to
act onto actin filaments as severing and
capping
and that's very important because then
the activity of actin filaments is
important for
other the consequence in other
functional in the in the cell
and in the organs in general so perhaps
cell division
the adhesion and motility and also of
course the muscle contraction
so miss uh let's say misfolding
of the uh the gelfline could mislead
then
after all the um the downstream then
signaling our pathways um and so i'm
more interesting into understanding the
pathological mechanism mediated by
the uh the gelatinous mutants and here
the mutation
is a single point mutations that fall
only into the second domain
that as a consequence the protein is
during its maturation
to be released into the plasma into
in the golgi apparatus has become more
flexible
and instable and then become more uh
accessible to some proteases in golgi
apparatus
and as a as a consequence the proteins
start to be cleaved by these proteases
especially the furin
protease and the pathological part
is this aggregates from that come
from these small fragments and
actually the classification of these
of these gelatinous mutants is based
onto the deposits of
these aggregate small fragments
in in the body uh now in from a
structural point of view
the study of the whole actually domains
or the full length
protein is pretty much challenging
because it's very dynamic and very
flexible and if you can remember
i already mentioned that we struggle in
x-ray crystallography to crystallize
such a proteins because
they are very dynamic and then it's hard
to find the right
uh basically state or condition to get
it
and so most of the study that i'm going
to show you now is based on the isolated
second domain
where i try to find um
no you will see it later and
looking for exactly looking for a
therapeutic approach and how we can
study this psychological
mechanism mediated by the mutated uh
gelcoming they found this group overbake
from belgium that have developed
nanobodies
to target gelsini mutants and they found
this np11
that seems to this is just a summary
from their paper that seems to
actually really prevent the uh the
cleavage
of uh of gelsillin during exposed
translation which is
modification and they tested they did
different tests
in vitro and in vivo by this transgenic
mice where they found by injecting
already the nanobody in
in mouth there was an improvement into
the muscle contraction and seems when
the actin
is again functional correct functioning
correctly
uh means that somehow the mutant is
again working as
the one type so from a very
bad resolution actually they found they
thought at the beginning that
um this is the isolated again second
domain they thought that this nanobody
going to act or bind into the fury
binding site and then
as a consequence prevent the cleavage of
gelsillin
but it seems that the nanobody is
finding in
a different position on the protein
and so for me what's really interesting
this nanobody and to see how we can use
it for my project
and to see if it's actually really can
have the same
effect let's say of protection or
preventing this
uh this appearance virtualizes on other
uh journaling mutants and if so
i wanted to go further into
understanding of
the molecular mechanism of protection by
means
preventing the misfolding and
stabilizing the protein
and can i use it also as as a tool as a
structural tool to crystallize it
perhaps
both actually the isolate domain or the
full length
and so of course the first step was for
me is to produce all the
component of this research so all the
proteins that i need the nanobody
and here's some actually examples from
the characterization that i have been
doing
either by just biochemical
characterization
or with and without the nanobody with or
without the fury
and see what is the effect and if i can
see some uh
effect on of stabilization and
preventing this
cleavage and effectively that was the
case
and also by some biophysical
characterization so to test also the
thermal stability
of these uh mutants with or without the
nanobody
and here's just a scheme our summary of
all the
research that i have done actually so
again all these details are in
in my paper um and so
yeah and so what i found that in the
presence of the nanobody
even if i have a mutated isolated domain
of gersoline
and the furine the protein seems to be
protected and not anymore cleaved
all right for the third aim of my
project was to use it as a
structural tool and so i set up i don't
know i can't remember even how many
crystal plates i have set up and um a
month is
when we went to uh to test all this
data we get a very exciting three data
sets where we found
for the first time actually uh uh
in literature we solved uh the
three-dimensional structure of this
mutant d100
uh for the first time so that's where
something was very renewable
and that was thanks to the nanobody um
again it's again only on the isolated
second domain
um with the nanobody that you can see
here
and effectively the nanobody is binding
into
a different uh binding size rather than
onto the fury cleavage side but however
it's able to to stabilize
and protect the protein from being
cleaved
so yeah here is a link for my paper that
you can check
later on for further details um but i
didn't want to stop here i want to
have further insight into the impact of
this mutation
and what they did is something called
superimpose of
having a model and then you superimpose
the two protein together to see what are
the more
the differences and so here in blue is
my experimental data that i resolved
with the nanobody and so the mutated
version of
gelsolene and the yellow gold color
is the white type and as you can see
they are pretty much
super impulse except for the here some
differences into the length of the c
terminal
and terminal and also you can see that
the coordination of calcium
it seems to be restored somehow and so
the even the mutant in complex with the
nanobody able to
um complicate with calcium or you
remember
i hope that calcium is important for the
activity of
um of gelfiline but i want to
go further into that and together with
my former
bioinformatician we did the simulation
where we
uh start to stimulate the activity of
gelatine in
presence of the nanobody and without
and as you can see here that after a
certain time of simulation
we found that um the c terminal is
pretty much
dynamic and flex flexible and it could
be
that's why uh the fearing cleavage side
when we have the mutation it's pretty
much exposed to the exosolar
environment and then the furin able to
start the cleavage
of the of the of the protein
whereas when we have the nanobody it's
pretty much
much dynamic so much and not flexible
and seems that the
protein is similar to the uh actually
the initial
uh to the the first or the starting uh
confirmation of the state and so that's
why probably
we uh the virtualizers of this
appearance ritualizes
it started when we have the mutation and
the nanobody is able really to stabilize
it and prevent
this cleavage and so by combining my
experimental data and also
computational data we were able really
to understand the impact of this
mutation and start to propose
therapeutic approaches
all right this brings me to the fir the
actually second example from my
uh from my phd this iron channel called
acid sensing iron channel
and actually so far uh there have been
identified sex is a form of these
uh ion channels so they they can
actually combine between each other and
uh in a different composition and based
on this composition and based on
where they are uh in our bodies they
function differently
even though they belong the same family
of uh of
uh of ion channels and so again they are
proton gated ion channels that only open
in
certain conditions and in this case if
it's
um basically have shown to be
activated only under a certain condition
called acidosis and and what's more
focused into the study of asic 1a which
is mainly expressed in in the brain
and it seems that when it's expressed in
conditions such as stroke epilepsy or
multiple sclerosis
it becomes permeable to
sodium ions and recently they have shown
that they're also permeable to calcium
and in this case it's very important
because calcium is the second messenger
in the cells that
mitigates really a number of uh
downstream signals and in the case of
aces once
they are still unknown this downstream
signaling
but what is known that upon the
activation of asic
it leads to the degeneration of cells so
the apoptosis
and so yeah the death of neurons
and so for me it was a really
interesting target to
um to look for a therapeutic approach
and to understand uh these downstream
signaling
but from structural point of view it was
more interesting in having more
information into the three-dimensional
or the architecture of this ion channel
um there are now a number actually of uh
of
structure presence in the protein data
bank where we deposit most of uh
of the protein structures and so as you
can see here the topology
of this membrane or ion channel is uh
like that where you have the
c and terminal in intracellular you have
the transmembrane domain
which is made only by alpha helix and
you have an x a huge extra actually
uh domain combined that alpha and beta
sheets
and the most interesting part here is
this pocket called ph rocket where it's
believe that
um here where the the iron channels
start to
sense this variation of uh
of yeah of um of protons
all right so the goal of my project back
then was really to understand the
architecture of this
uh ion channel and then to start design
uh small molecules that could target
inhibit actually the activity of this
ion channel
and to do so i had plans from combining
different techniques between
the starting with computational data
and all the way down to from in vitro
and to to vivo so to test in my
intragenic mice that they have already
the disease perhaps stroke or multiple
sclerosis
uh to test these small molecules that i
will be
already developing together with the
protein
actually this paper i can mention so
much results about
because the paper will be hopefully
published soon
but just to give you an idea what we
have done um
from a computational studies i start to
look for small molecules that have
specific characteristics so should they
should be specific for asic one
and not to other iso forms and also
important into the
in the iron channel but also to be able
to pass this
blood brain barrier so this is kind of
membranes that protect our
brain from any chemical or any stuff
that we take
normally or daily in into our body
and so to develop a drug that works into
a protein
uh in the brain it has to have the
characteristic with
uh that can uh pass the blood-brain
barrier
um and so i start with together with
chemists that of course they will
synthesize and
find for me of course these small
molecules together
we start really designing a virtual
library more than 60 small molecules
inspired by these molecules called
limited zane
and then we start ranking them in in
silico to see
by using our model to see which ones
they should
they can actually fit and bind to the
ion channel
and by this means like they have the
best binding energy with the proteins
and from those ones we choose the best
we synthesize them and then i start to
test them with
uh with my with iron channel
all right and so this is a a summary of
uh how i was trying to express and
uh to basically to produce
in a huge quantity this iron channel
um by using different systems and so
to ensure that i'm getting the best
constructs for also for structural
biology
i designed more than actually than 16
constructs
uh in with a different truncation into
the membrane
membrane protein and then i start to
screen for
different expression systems i start
with bacteria which is the most
simple one and then i move to more
high complex systems such as a mammalian
expression system but i found that uh
asset mice or insect cells were the best
for this kind of
expression as you can see here this
first example for some
constructs and you can see i was having
the gfp
tag that allowed me to follow up
basically the expression
and also during the purification steps
and then of course i start with the
biochemical and biophysical
characterization of the ion channel
with and without of course the small
molecules to see the effect
and now the next step would be then to
move to
structural data cool so
yeah again this paper for uh with asic
and the small molecules is coming soon
so hopefully you can have a look into
the paper
all right this brings me to the third
example which i'm
now currently working on the gpcr and
mainly i'm focused on the study of what
they call the adhesion gpcr
subfamily just a reminder about gpcr
they are very well known about the with
these
seven transmembrane parts so
the gpcrs they have the internal
extracellular that exposed to the
environment and interacts with chemical
ligands or
mechanical signals that activate
actually the receptor
and they have the transmembrane domain
so
as you can see here made by composed by
seven trans membrane
and the c terminal is attached with
g proteins composed by the alpha beta
gamma
domains and and so upon the activation
or the interaction of the n terminal
with ligands or signal they activate the
receptor and as a consequence they
then activate the g proteins and through
the g proteins then a number of
downstream signaling
uh signals uh pathways are activated
now um yeah so after the
the nobel prize from kupilka uh in
2010 uh it had
really made an impact into understanding
uh the gpcr in in in details
and in deep actually um especially
into the different conformational states
of these gpcrs but it's still
very challenging to study gpcrs because
they are
can be found in different active states
as well
um and also to crystallize them to
have uh to characterize them also
functionally
because they get really stressed after
um
getting them out from the membranes and
nanobodies again
they have shown to be a really
interesting tool in structural biology
also with the gpcr
because as i mentioned before they can
be used to stabilize
the the gpcr in a certain confirmation
and then we can
target uh this um confirmation in
specific and rational way
just a little bit uh history about the
teaching gpcr and why i'm interesting
into understanding the adhesions gpcrs
because uh these addition gprs they have
been
thought for a very long time to belong
to
class b and this is one of the classes
of gpcr's but after
2003 basically they start to be
classified differently
um and from 2012 they start to attract
the attention of
scientists because they seem to be
really involved in a different
um any different uh function
i mean physiological uh and pathological
uh
mechanisms and so yeah um
okay um the addition just a little bit
about the state of art about these
addition gpcrs
uh they are the second largest uh
subfamily of gpcr's indeed they have
been identified
33 members in humans and they as i
mentioned before they have been
classified to class b
but recently they have been classified
as a separated family
there is a number of there are numbers
actually
of genetic and cell biology studies that
have shown
that addition gpcr involves a number of
human diseases such as in the
development of
tumors into immune system especially in
dysfunction of the immune system as well
as in
uh neuro neurological disorders and so
again for me then
this exciting and uh as a target to
start to look for
uh uh design drugs against
addition gpcr um
but from my structural point of view
more interesting having information into
the architecture of these adhesions and
you can as you can see here
these are the 33 members they have the
canonical
topology of gpcr
structure where you have the c terminal
intracellular we have the transmembrane
domain here the
seven transmembrane and you have uh
this huge as this is the main hallmark
difference between gpcr
and addition gpcr it's a huge xfl domain
that is composed by a number of
sub domains that have different
functions so there
are still unknown what is the
functionality and
the the structure of these domains as
well
yeah so again the the addition gccr even
though they
have attracted the attention recently to
scientists they're still
the most unstudied
family of gpcr yeah
again i'm more interested in having
information into the structural and
functional characteristics of these
additional gps i will show you what is
still
known about this these receptors and
addition gpcr especially if you look at
their
ssl and domain it's very
uh huge extra domain that can uh
be up to composed by more than 5 000
amino acids
and created by these two means that as i
mentioned before there's so
their structure of function of course so
and then
and again as the name suggested they
uh these domains probably uh mitigated
this adhesion so
between cell to cell or cell to
interaction with a protein present in
the extensor and matrix
and then mediated or activated the
receptor to mediate a number of
downstream signaling mediated by these
g-proteins
and so the hallmark of this addition gps
are is without your tertiary life with
mechanisms that
occur into the game domain
or this skull cleavage of the receptor
and it's believed that
the results cleavage occur during the
phototransmission modification of
the receptor so during the maturation of
the receptors before being even
migrated to the plasma membrane to the
cell membrane
and and this uh actually sequence was
uh believed for many years to be uh
unstructured and also
non-functional but um recently they have
shown that
it's important for uh starting the
activity of the receptor it's
still unknown whether it is uh
sufficient or not
for the whole activity and functionality
of the receptor
this sequence that is called stacca is
very important and it's proceeded
um uh here at the at the game domain
and it seems that by this uh
sequence uh the receptor starts
mediating this interaction
and or the activity then as a
consequence with the cheaper teams
however
all the players around whether it is
into the
extra in the external domain or
even into a transmembrane part or even
at the level of
intracellular level of two proteins what
are the downstream signaling
all of these things are still really
unknown and need to be
studied for them all right so
let's have a close look into the at this
game domain or this output
license and using domain on what is
called the shuffle sequence so
it's as again as i mentioned before this
game to me in specific folding and
correct
and precise clothing uh it acts as
as a protein basically because here we
have
we start to have this outer crystallisis
of the receptor
that take in a close look that upon this
cleavage
um we will have two fragments what is
called the ntf and ctf so the
internal fragments composed by the whole
extracellular
uh domain with also the gain domain and
the gps domain
uh that is within the game domain and
then the shuffle
type uh that connects basically both
uh fragments to the ctf which is
uh composed by the transmembrane domain
and the
part of the c terminal now these two
fragments are not um covalently
associated but rather by a bunch of
hydrogen
bonds that keep them associated together
and then
as i said before it's pouring
during the maturation of the receptor
and then these two together
uh two fragments basically start to
migrate to the
uh to the cell membrane where they then
uh wait for probably for the ligands or
the signals
to start being uh to activate it and so
the downstream signaling
um is there any uh structures
or details in of this addition gpcr
yes and no because the only two
structures available so far are the
uh only related to the gain domain so
only to this
part here and there is no uh information
about the full length of receptor
and this is probably because here is the
challenge of studying
such receptors in structural biology
because
again i just remind you that the
exercise domain is very big
and also very flexible probably because
the presence of all these remains
and so this makes the receptor really
hard to
uh to be to be characterized
structurally
unless you use cryom or tomography that
work uh the best and actually this
receptor are optimum for this kind of
techniques
because of their size so uh in 2012 they
were uh
deposits two structures of the game
domain from two different additions that
actually gave ray
give further insights into the folding
and the architecture of this
this domain and that was very of course
important
into understanding the functional
scissors um here i can go quickly just
to give you
um why we need to know all this kind of
herb formation because
we then we will be able to
target the the receptors at different
pointing
points uh different binding sites and
whether it is into the
in the excessor domain or the
transmembrane or even
in the in intra intracellular parts
even working on the two proteins and
this will be very helpful because then
we can also intervene
into neurological disorders or and
tumerogenesis pathways
so for my postdoc project i'm aiming to
understand the architecture of the
prolens but also to some parts of the
of the addition gpcrs um in order to be
then able to target these receptors
and so as you already probably start to
understand from my presentation
the most important part is to produce
your receptors to start characterize it
functionally and structurally
and with this uh i'm using crayons in
the particle crayon
um of the apple receptors so the
receptor without any ligand
uh in specific functional states or with
um actually and uh with
other protein parts partners uh
including the g-proteins
but also this does this doesn't exclude
the fact that i will work also in
a small fragment so in some truncated
parts of the receptor
uh by using x-ray transphobia and of
course this
would be along with computational
analysis because this will help us to
predict some information about the
receptors
um just will take you quickly into the
workflows our
work again the design of the best uh
constructs the protein expression
purification and then of course the
structural analysis
of your receptor everything's
for me important because especially from
the cell culture if your contract is
designed well
and uh if everything is made correctly
in the fill culture
in the by means expression and the
design of
your viruses um is made well then
you can work easily in the west lab for
purification and the
functional characterization it's not
always smooth like that but
uh for me uh it's important that i start
to have a good expression of my receptor
in order then to do
uh all the other characterization and
in uh there are different actually uh
guidelines and
rules that you can follow in the film
culture and we
in our lab we adapt for example uh the
uh the guidelines from permafisher
together with uh with what we
experienced in our daily life in the
cell culture
and korea we created our guideline our
rules and i think it's very important
here to mention that
what makes the things work in the cell
culture is
the team work together because yeah
that's how we do in our labs
um so once you start let's move to the
first part which is the protein
expression where you have to decide
which
cell system to use and also uh i use
faculty viruses for infecting insect
cells
i found that that's very good because
then i can move to
having a good generation or high
saturation of viruses that then will
allow me to
large uh produce my my receptor
this is a closer look into our incubator
where
you can see that we start with a very
small scale where
this from c zero because it's hidden
it's an aesthetic way
and then we move to uh b zero
b one and p two that t two allows us
then to move to a large scale expression
we also check the saturation of viruses
so that's very important again i have
the gp as a tag that will help me to
make sure that my receptor is pressing
but i also want to make sure that i have
the good saturation and the good amount
of
viruses to infect myself and
also having a good quality of protein
once you have done then you can move to
the wet lab where you start the
purification and picking up i'm trying
now to set up actually
a protocol for purification and
characterize a characterization of these
additions since
there's still not much known about it so
this is challenging and that's exciting
actually for me
yeah and this is kind of an uh an
overview
how i do the work so yeah this is the
the flatmate that i choose for
and how do i design my constructs for
the expression in
insect cells and by using faculty
viruses
and then i move to small normally i
start with a small scale
purification and then once i have
already set up kind of protocol then i
move to a large-scale
expression uh and on the and therefore
uh purification
and all of this kind of in the loop
because we always try to
optimize the conditions in order to have
the best
uh yeah purifies receptors
all right so why i need to understand
the structure of
uh and function of these adhesions of
course because if you already
have got it i want to understand the
molecular mechanism
signaling receptors and this will help
me then to target them
rationally again in a specific and
rational
way to find the best small molecules
or ligands such as non-body
to target this receptor in specific
diseases uh again
uh nanobodies are really a very exciting
tool now
nowadays in structural biology they are
used for different techniques and for
different purposes
and especially in the case of gpcrs and
i
hope i convince you that um the
structural based design is a really
novel
opportunity to rationally design small
molecules or ligands for targeting
specific diseases
but all this kind of academic work is
still in what we call the drug discovery
so looking for the best
drugs that can then be developed
and so can enter into clinical trials
and be approved hopefully but this is
really
a long journey that takes a lot of time
uh yeah that brings me to the end of my
presentation
and i want to spend uh one moment to
thank really all the people that have
been involved and supervised me during
this time and
still supervising me and now monitoring
me
uh patrick during my uh my postdoc
position now
um i want to thank also my my phd father
martino for really helping me overtime
during my phd and
i learned a lot from him but also i want
to thank
again gitko for giving me the
opportunity to present
my work and all the people the companies
that have been involved
in uh in realizing my projects
and of course you guys you can reach me
always whether it is through
email or through social media on
instagram on twitter you can also check
our website
in the lab and have further details on
what we do
so if you have any questions curiosities
you can always
reach me yeah that's that's it so
thank you so much for listening today
thank you all for your informative
presentation
as a reminder to our audience if you'd
like
to ask a question please do so now just
click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for i'm all i know
you had some additional comments would
you like to go ahead and provide those
now
yeah thanks michelle answer uh just a
minor uh error that i have made during
my speech about the novel prize it was
not in 2010
but 2012 and so that's very important
and also the pictures that i have
provided during my presentation in the
last part in the cell culture
they were giving in by our uh very smart
phd student
now allah david speak he helped me
during that
images and so i want to thank him
and that's it i'm waiting for a question
guys
okay let's go ahead and get started your
first question is
how do you extract membrane proteins
from the cell membranes yeah that's very
good question actually because as you
already had the idea that they are very
challenging and so you had to get them
out from the
phospholipid composition and the
of the membranes of the cell membranes
and so we use different
methods uh the most used method is using
detergent
that kind of mimic um
the this uh lipid composition of the
membranes
and so uh to choose also the detergent
or the best detergent for the
for the syllabilization as we call it is
um is we screen a library of detergents
and then we choose the best one that
allows us to
extract the best out of our receptor
from the membranes
uh there's also different techniques
like using amphiboles
or nanodiscs that also help
into the extraction of your your
membrane protein
yeah i hope i answered your question
well
okay thank them all let's go ahead and
move on to your next question
okay it says are you familiar maybe
with gpcr is it muscarinic
achr do you know
maybe which is the first protein or
target
or is there universal protein target of
ca2 plus
after passing through the machr does
that make sense
uh yes um so it's very complicating
actually question is very good
because nc4 receptors are actually the
most characterized gpcr receptor and
um i don't want to take so much time to
answer this because it's very
complicated
and there's a lot of details into that
so for whom asked me this question you
can actually contact me via email and i
can get back to you with really deep
insights into that because
they are very actually also interesting
target as a tpcr
uh interact discovery yeah but from
structural point of view
they are well characterized there is a
lot of investigation into their
the active inactive states in complex
with other ligands with
g proteins as well um so
okay i have another question here for
you can you please elaborate a little
bit how you plan to use
hdx mx in drug discovery
uh can you say it again michelle
i how i'm trying for you sorry
eight sure can you elaborate
a little bit how you plan to use hdx
ms in drug discovery
um yeah that's also very good question
but it's going beyond my expertise i
don't
use ms and so i'm not the best person to
ask this question
but definitely it's actually used for um
uh for when you don't have like
uh experimental information about your
uh
your um your your your protein whether
it is syllable protein or
ah or membrane protein uh and so also
it's important that you have
know which type which part of the
protein you want to target
and which is the target like small
molecule or ligand that
would target it but i'm not the expert
in this field
so but if you're interesting again you
can contact me guys and
i could go in details into that
um okay thank you
all right next question how do you
choose a detergent for membrane
protein purification can it influence
the structural characterization
um how do we choose the detergent yeah
so
we basically start by the most used
detergent
and for example dtm and chs which is
a cholesterol lipid and so
we start with that and see what is the
outcome in kind of
um amount of protein extracted protein
and then if it's not the best or we see
that
we don't have a good amount for
structural or functional studies
and so we start creating different uh
detergent that
and then we compare them in order to see
which one is the best and so yeah we
start um
i remember during my phd i did like
really high throughput
uh screening to choose the best
detergent because it was
really difficult and challenging to find
the best one
all right
okay see another question here what
about the choice between
peptide synthesis and purification
nature
protein
um this
what do you mean with this i i can't
actually uh
get white what is the difference between
the synthesized peptide and
um i can actually get exactly what he
means with that
i'm sorry but again you can write me and
um we can go further in details into
that sorry
oh no problem okay let's go ahead and
move on to our next question
all right will the docking system
predict the antibody
cdr combinations on antigen without
structural information
that's very challenging if you don't
have the structural information then it
would be
kind of um yeah challenging because
okay you need a model in order to start
uh targeting or start to know how is the
the confirmation or the house is the 3d
of your your protein so
you need a very good model at the
beginning
if it's already answering your questions
okay many questions we're getting a lot
of great questions okay our next one
um how would it be possible to
target the adhesion gpcr from drug
discovery strategy
that's a very good question actually um
you already
got the idea how complex are these
receptors especially because of this
large uh exercise domain and very
flexible decorated by these um
by these uh domains and so
this instability or this uh complexity
make it
uh hard and so to target it you could
actually start by
getting the full length and then perhaps
using a nanobody that can stabilize
one part and then overall the structure
or you can basically truncate it and get
only parts of these receptors and on and
then on this part you can target
uh one nanobody or create a set of
mutants and that
how you could basically target it by
different way but
again the structural information is very
important in order to
to go into the functionality and
therefore then to target it
okay great looks like we have time for
one more question today
looks like this one came in a little bit
different but i'm going to try my best
to read this one to you
um you could see that the binding site a
structural artifact
effectively binds on the opposite side
to the furan cleavage site
that's actually was one of the questions
also from
one of the reviewers during our paper
because it's very important
um so um we are pretty sure
uh about the the binding site of the
of the nanobody on the that chelsea and
it's not in the fury because we got as i
mentioned three data set
and all these sets uh indicating that
the
nanobody is binding in the opposite uh
binding site in compared to the fluorine
cleavage side and so
we are pretty sure that this is the the
finding side of
uh nanoparty um now dr
deroza then my former uh supervisor
during my phd which is also
helped me a lot uh he's now doing a lot
of
uh also uh experiments with the full
length with the nanobiotic to see
and with other new terms to see
effectively this binding there so
yeah um
that's my answer we are pretty sure that
the finding side is there
and it's not a structural artifact
okay great thank you amal and do you
have any final comments for
our audience before we close today
yeah i want to thank them all for
joining us today
uh and uh i see so many questions but
again guys if you
have specific questions just reach me
out through
social media or through my email and
i'll try to help you
and i want to thank all uh the gift
console culture heroes for giving me
again this opportunity
very exciting thanks guys
thank you again amal for your time today
and for your important research
we would also like to thank labyrinths
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank
thank you and before we go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and
for their great questions again any
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by a mall via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye take care